[Musique]
tout le monde me disait que je rêvais
cette émission impossible mais je n'ai
jamais cessé d'y croire on est bon sur
le temps le meilleur chemin du point a
au point b n'est pas toujours une ligne
droite
les conditions sont très dures nous
allons nous retrouver dans une tempête
au juge être l encre si le vent dépasse
les 69
[Musique]
notre tour du monde a commencé à phuket
en thaïlande
nous avons traversé l'océan indien
contourner l'inde et atteint les émirats
arabes unis puis nous nous sommes
dirigés vers les seychelles via l'île
maurice belay qui file vers madagascar
et l'afrique du sud
après c'était la partie la plus dure
autour de l'afrique du sud en passant du
cap de bonne espérance à cas pour
arriver ensuite les 2 1 à midi vers le
brésil
une longue traversée de l'atlantique id
l'année suivante la plus longue étape a
été la traversée du pacifique
le skipper anatolie koulik qui a choisi
l'itinéraire
c'est le navire qui a fait de cette
traversée un voyage particulier c'était
un catamaran gonflables pliable à deux
coques avec un mât et une grande voile
pourquoi un catamaran est pas un yacht
ou un autre type de bateau d'abord parce
que une fois pliée le catamaran
peut-être transporter n'importe où
facilement deuxièmement naviguer sur un
catamaran est une expérience incroyable
on a l'impression de voler il glisse sur
l'eau est plus important personne
n'avait encore jamais navigué autour du
monde sur un catamaran gonflables dont
personne ne pouvait être sûr que ce soit
même possible pour une telle croisière
vous avez besoin d'un équipage solide
des gens sur qui vous pouvez compter en
toutes circonstances
nous sommes tous différents
à terre nous travaillons dans des
domaines différents mais nous avons des
points communs
nous sommes de sibérie nous sommes des
explorateurs et chacun de nous a eu du
succès je suis par exemple champions de
voile en russie je m'appelle n'y avait
ni kowaleski je suis docteur en
ingénierie
j'ai toujours admiré gainey pour sa
détermination inébranlable et parce
qu'il termine toujours ceux qui
commencent entre nous on l'appelle
ministre des affaires étrangères dans
chaque nouveau pays il faut passer des
formalités administratives savoir
attendre est essentielle
[Musique]
stanislav berio skins est ingénieur en
systèmes d'automatisation et champion de
voile en russie cette petite boîte
contient toutes les cartes dont nous
avons besoin en tant que navigateur
c'est mon travail de saisir les données
le vent est fort
joeri maas los boys f est ingénieur en
chef à l'institut d'automatisation et
d'électro mettrie une branche sibérienne
de l'académie des sciences de russie est
champion russe d'alpinisme c'est grâce à
lui que tous nos appareils fonctionnent
les plus beaux regarde le celui là avec
ses yeux gris pierre guénette h quine et
le cameraman je m'en vais filmer c'est
un sacré bonhomme toujours là pour filer
un coup de main sur le pont et enfin le
capitaine anatoly koulik il un doctorat
en ingénierie et construit des
catamarans anatolie coliques et un
skipper de génie c'est lui qui a élaboré
le trajet il connaît les conditions
climatiques les cours en ligne les fonds
buteur on sera dans un port magnifique
allez on fait le ménage c'est fait mieux
que ça
qu'est ce qu'un capitaine c'est
quelqu'un qui est responsable des
décisions finales
ils m'ont fait confiance
[Musique]
on nous demande souvent ce qui nous
motive ce qui nous fait mettre notre vie
en jeu la curiosité
le rêve de voir des choses que peu
d'autres ont vu c'est vrai en quelque
sorte
mais la raison principale est de voir
ses limites de se connaître
les anciens croyez que le monde était un
livre et ceux qui ne voyageait pas de
vers lire la même page encore et encore
cependant si vous décidez de défier les
océans préparez vous à des surprises et
des dangers qui peuvent vous coûter la
vie
[Musique]
la mère a le pouvoir de vous laisser
passer ou de vous tuer à tout moment
n'importe quel navire turc où les
quelques sur sa taille
la première étape et l'océan indien le
troisième plus grand océan après le
pacifique et l'atlantique
[Musique]
e
il est entouré de quatre continents
australie afrique ainsi et antarctiques
[Musique]
marco polo a été le premier européen à
traverser l'océan indien
aujourd'hui cet océan est devenue une
immense route de transit reliant les
principaux ports maritimes du monde
[Musique]
l'océan est une expérience exaltante
chaque jour et plein de surprises
une douzaine de baleines ou des passes à
tribord
[Musique]
nous n'avons pas de toi pas de soute pas
de cabines pas de douche rien nous
vivons ici littéralement sur les vagues
de l'océan
[Musique]
fin de quart c'est à moi maintenant
le jour la veille dure trois à quatre
heures
la nuit c'est une toute autre histoire
vous
parfois il faut faire de veille en une
nuit pendant la première vous pouvez
être encore alerte mais pour la seconde
il se peut que vous teniez à peine
debout
vous essayez de vous ressaisir de
mesurer la vitesse du vent et de faire
face aux énormes vagues qui arrivent par
intervalles vous prenez des douches
salle est ce que le vent souffle
constamment parfois j'ai été congelé
pendant toute la durée du carnage mais
vous ne pouvez jamais lâcher la barre le
vent peut être mauvais avec des vagues
jusqu'à 3 4 mètres de haut qui font
tanguer le bateau mais il ne faut pas
perdre le contrôle je m'étais le
catamaran l'équipage la nourriture et
l'eau des environs de tonnes le pire
moment c'est juste avant l'aube
pas la fin d'une veille on est vraiment
fatiguée on a besoin de dormir
l'attenté consul pour 3 4 personnes et
nous sommes 5
il y a toujours quelqu'un à la barre
l'eau éclabousse l'intérieur de la tente
on a l'impression de galoper sur un
cheval ivre sur une route sinueuse
quand la mer est calme la chaleur
devient insupportable il faut se mettre
dans l'eau sous le catamaran pour se
refroidir
mais dans cette position on peut être la
proie des requins il faut faire
attention au moindre nuage et on
commence à comprendre pourquoi les gens
qui se perdaient en mer devenait fou et
s'entretuer les astronautes comme les
marins se lasse assez vite de leur
camarade de chambrée nous allons chasser
l'inconvénient de toulon voyage ou
expédition grâce aux jeans chaque
seconde chaque minute si on continue nos
jours et nuits vous voyez les mêmes
visages qui est je lis need you c'est
difficile
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce ne sont pas des gens ordinaires qui
font ce genre d'expédition
donc il faut avoir une certaine force de
caractère j'aimerais que chacun d'entre
eux est un expert en génie des sports
extrêmes
bien sûr qu'il nous arrive de nous
disputer
et puis on arrête sinon ça peut devenir
tellement tendue qu'on a besoin d'aller
à différentes parties du bateau pour se
calmer
je suis parti à la proue où il ne
pouvait pas me voir je me suis assis là
et j'ai pleuré
[Musique]
comme ça tu restes là tu pleures un
quart d'heure après ça s'arrange
il faut bien nous avons un long chemin à
parcourir que faire d'autre si ce n'est
patienter nous avons appris à être
patient
nous savons tous jouer de la guitare et
chanter et grâce à ça les problèmes
semblent disparaît
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
soit
[Musique]
bien
g
[Musique]
rires
[Applaudissements]
je
ce qui le rend
il pleut souvent dans l'océan indien et
il y à de très violents tempête
je ne vois rien j'ai de l'eau plein les
yeux
là
alors on fait quoi bande d'abrutis on
fait semblant de naviguer vous n'êtes
pas rester à la maison
bonne question jeune homme raffiné que
je suis et me voilà dans ce trou paumé
nous nous sommes retrouvés dans
plusieurs situations dangereuses quand
nous naviguions entre l'inde et le sri
lanka un bateau pirate nous a approchés
il fonçait droit sur nous nous avons
compris qu'ils allaient nous faire
prisonniers politiques à garder son sang
froid a pointé du doigt les récits faits
l'écart entre les deux bateaux n'étaient
plus que 2 200 m les triais sonné du
corps et il était armé et donc nous
avons passé le récif le trô ne vient pas
faire ça c'est qu'on flat bhl c'est
comme un ballon
nous avons sauté les récifs les pirates
ne pouvait pas faire ça rapporte qu'à
droite lumière j'aurais aimé vous
puissiez entendre comme leurs cornes se
sont tus tout d'un crime pourrait voter
nul il nous avait presque
[Musique]
pétanque capitaine coli qui a dit que la
cuisine c'était pour lui c'est parce que
je sais cuisiner délicieux c'est la zone
du travail du cuisinier
pour moi c'est comme jouer au piano on
soulève le couvercle du piano
si on y ranger la vaisselle propre une
toile des louches j'ai décidé de
cuisiner
parce que si tout le monde s'y mettait
il n'y aurait plus de scènes dans la
cuisine
[Musique]
elle est allée voir le nous avons
attrapé une belle daurade
si l'appel coryphène dans l'atlantique
et maï-maï dans le pacifique
oh
regardez combien il y en a des poissons
bien sûr des poissons tout un bon
j'avais un poisson de supermarchés frais
ou surgelés ne peut être comparé un
poisson qui vient de pêcher le poisson
est toujours vivant alors qu anatolie le
découpe vous pouvez le manger cru
fantastique espèce de boucher comment
faire autrement
c'est ça la vie dans l'océan
quand tu te réveilles pour le tour de
garde du matin anatoly te sert le café
pas maillot c'est juste parfait
c'est du café fait par le capitaine du
vrai quoi
l'eau douce est particulièrement
précieuse lorsque vous êtes sur l'océan
nous sommes en pré nier de sel mais le
capitaine ne nous permet pas de nous
laver à l'eau douce
sauf s'il y en a en abondance souvent il
faut prendre une douche sous la pluie
c'est fou
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les humains produisent beaucoup de
déchets
les déchets plastiques mais il ne faut
pas les jeter dans l'océan
on dépose tous nos déchets en plastique
dans un grand sac poubelle nous le
jetons il faut arriver à un port nous
avons apporté tout le plastique nous
avions
[Musique]
le catamaran nécessite un entretien
constant chaque jour il y a quelque
chose qui tombe à réparer
les conditions sont dures des appareils
pourrissent et des éléments de contact
disparaissent
il fallait tout le temps réparer quelque
chose au début nous utilisions des
bâtons pour renforcer le bateau après
nous avons eu une situation délicate au
cours d'une veille nocturne koulik est
venu me voir disant que youri et
guennadi penser que notre bateau ne
pouvait pas aller plus loin il voulait
abandonner à mi chemin j'étais
complètement contre j'ai dit que s'il y
avait quelque chose de cassé
il fallait réparer on s'assoit discute
et décide de continuer avec
d'incessantes réparation
[Musique]
effectuant diverses tâches nécessaires
cet appareil permet d'étudier
l'atmosphère testant des aliments
lyophilisés
quel est ton vous préférez cappuccino
tests dans des purificateurs d'eau
c'est assez dégueulasse mais ces blocs
aux tables
[Musique]
au cours d'une vie calme il est possible
de profiter de la vue pour se rendre
compte que le ciel l'océan et le petit
catamaran ne font qu'un
[Musique]
c'est fantastique on ne voit ça nulle
part ailleurs
s'ils ont dessiné sa personne ne croira
que ça existe
[Musique]
l'océan comporte tant d'informations et
d'énergie des quantités colossales
c'est d'aimer gâteau il y à 100 fois
plus de vie dans l'océan que sur terre
plus de vie plus d'information plus
d'énergie de l'énergie et des données à
g 2 milliards d'années et l'océan à 2 3
à 4 milliards d'années la planète d'être
5 milliards
[Musique]
incroyable
où sommes nous kalil l'île au trésor
oui elle gagné a un peu perdu la tête
c'est facile ici
[Musique]
nous nous arrêtons à saisine pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord refaire des
réserves de nourriture et d'eau ensuite
faire des papiers réparé le catamaran
nous sommes cette fois à l'île maurice
en train de passer les contrôles
administratifs habituel
c'est ici que nous passons d'un
catamaran à un tri mar nous avons passé
les douanes mauricienne
plus et pourquoi pas de telles beau
gosse on a tout pour plaire
m
[Musique]
souffle et les courgettes
[Applaudissements]
c'est un légume un peu comme une pomme
de terre ils disent il paraît que ça
pousse sur les arbres qu'est ce que
c'est sa calebasse
c'est un genre de calebasse comme je l
ai déjà dit puisque quand tu es venu me
voir
tu as dit que tu étais fou et je te dis
non et nous sommes fous toi tu es normal
c'était le directeur général de taylor
smith
l'entreprise qui nous a donné une place
pour construire le trimaran
il s'appelle thierry il a dit que nous
étions des drags des fous maintenant ils
disent et nous les foot
nous allons au travail tous les jours et
rentrons chez nous le soir vous vous
êtes des hommes normaux
cette a coûté combien rien du tout ils
ont proposé eux-mêmes c'est normalement
3000 $ de l'heure ils ont dit servez
vous ans et de bon coeur avec la grue
quinze personnes nous ont aidés à nous
remettre à l'eau
à
les gens sont si gentils ici à maurice
on a entendu des histoires effrayantes
sur ses habitants on disait qu'ils
étaient méfiants méchant wheeler seul
problème le racisme ici non il n'y a pas
de racisme ici aucun way
à la moindre occasion nous contactons
nos familles qui s'inquiètent
bien entendu toute la sibérie suivait
l'expédition
c'était très stressant pour nous nous
suivions leur position sur une carte en
ligne des gens appeler notre bureau
demander comment va l'équipe âge
aujourd'hui
et quand nous ne recevions pas d'appel
de leur part c'était la panique bien sûr
ce n'est pas la mer c'est l'océan les
vagues atteignent 10 mètres soit la
longueur du bateau nous connaissons les
risques auxquels ils sont confrontés et
nous sommes très inquiets
de retour sur l'océan
[Musique]
une violente tempête
les membrures sont mises à mal
il faut faire une escale à dour ban sur
la côte sud-africaine et y passer une
semaine pour des réparations deux
poteaux se sont cassés sur les
stabilisateurs gauche
voilà un deux trois quatre planches nous
ont aidés à naviguer encore 70 km après
l'accident
sans ça je ne sais pas ça aurait été la
fin on seront un marché pour trouver les
pièces nécessaires et de l'acier
[Musique]
et il est ensuite temps d'embarquer pour
une navigation difficile dans les eaux
meurtrière du cap de bonne espérance
pour entrer dans l'océan atlantique
fatigué on décide de prendre un jour de
repos
et sur les conseils de locaux d'aller au
lac de sainte lucie
les cochons dans le village de ma
grand-mère était plus gros
se baigner ici ça ne donne pas très
envie
[Musique]
une girafe une vraie
monde
[Musique]
il ya un courant puissant ici qui pousse
vers la côte
donc il faut être prudent
les plaisanciers locaux sont prêts à
nous aider avant de partir ils nous ont
mis en garde contre les courants les
plus dangereux et expliquer de quoi se
méfier
pas facile d'entrer
c'est juste que s'il fait mauvais temps
c'est difficile d'entrer à cause de la
houle
mais si tu es dedans ça va c'est là que
tout le monde panique c'est le courant
du cap de bonne espérance
oui par la vase y aller vers l'avant
et nous allons au cas on est quelques
photos
[Musique]
le cap de bonne espérance nous attend
après ce sera l'océan atlantique
royet volets ps2
[Musique]
hier mme nasty plus alors manière pas
bons deals à mort
[Musique]
ja
ben oui
[Musique]
bague à l'arrière du bac
attention
on a salué le cap de bonne espérance
avec une chanson et il a répondu avec
des rafales et une vague géante
pour être honnête il fait ça à tout le
monde des vagues mortels se forment ici
et il est difficile de faire face au
vent dans cette région là où les océans
indien et atlantique se rencontre on et
moi signe et on a eu droit à des vagues
de 8 ou 9 m des rafales jusqu'à 30 ou 40
noeuds d'un autre trimaran a rebondi sur
les vagues
les vagues sont montés boom et ça
descend
ça va une de plus vasco da gama était le
premier à passer le cap de bonne
espérance
il a obtenu le droit de s'asseoir face à
la reine d'angleterre et d'autres rois
d'europe
quiconque ayant passé le cap près de la
côte est et c'était des héros ils
étaient autorisés à s'asseoir à la table
de monarque
il avait le droit de boire gratuitement
dans n'importe quelle taverne et de
porter un anneau en argent à l'oreille
gauche
donc notre capitaine anatoly koulik à un
anneau en argent à l'oreille gauche
c'était dur mais nous l'avons fait sans
aide mais c'est ça je sais pas pour vous
mais moi je suis à terre le drapeau nous
ne l'avons pas levé russe
[Musique]
on fait le tour du cap une ville de mar
le monde entier est à nos pieds
oui
[Musique]
à
j'ai grandi ici je sais que c'est la
partie la plus risquée de la côte
sud-africaine en appelant le service
national de secours j'ai vu un bateau en
train d'être soulevé par une énorme
vague j'ai compris qu'il était en
difficulté
alors ils pensent que c'est une heureuse
coïncidence que les gens de ce bateau
lui ai demandé de l'aider à bord j'ai
quelques pièces pour le renforcer
[Musique]
j'ai un immense respect pour ce que vous
faites si j'étais plus jeune j'irai avec
vous quel âge avez-vous 58 puis c'est
notre capitaine a 56 ans j'ai cinquante
trois mois donc tu à notre âge tu peux
venir demain au hockey j'irai avec vous
cerci d'accord merci beaucoup merci
en russie les périples en bateau
gonflable sont très populaires
la russie est un grand pays mais a très
peu d'accès au maire chaude
[Musique]
les plaisanciers locaux ont été surpris
de voir les gens se lancer dans un tel
voyage sur un bateau aussi fragile
[Musique]
avant de partir ils nous ont invités
dans une boîte de nuit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce n'est pas ma dernière fois ici sommes
sûrs de revenir
[Musique]
je suis si triste
l'afrique du sud nous a réservé un
accueil si chaleureux
[Musique]
e
visibilité
rien juste 0,1 brouillard fait peur
trouveront un bateau et il suffit de
deux secondes pour entrer en collision
hier pour quelque chose
je ne peux pas juger de la distance je
vois un navire arrivé et je ne peux pas
dire où il va j'ai pris peur je cris
capitaine pascoli cours sur le pont en
disant que se passe-t-il un bateau
arrive tout va bien il suffit de tourner
un peu arrête de me déranger pour rien
d'accord alors je vois un navire je
tourne un peu à gauche puis un peu à
droite je me dis c'est fini on va entrer
en collision koulik coliques vient
pourquoi tu n'as rien dit il prend la
barre change de cap en une fraction de
seconde et nous passons juste sous la
proue du navire
sinon il nous aurait écrasé
[Musique]
l'océan atlantique la température de
l'eau y est beaucoup plus basse que dans
les océans pacifique et indien
c'est en grande partie dû à l'influencé
des océans arctique et antarctique du
brouillard et des pluies torrentielles
sont fréquents ici
[Musique]
le cap est mis sur la namibie naviguer
directement vers le brésil à travers
l'océan atlantique serait très difficile
car nous étions confrontés à des
courants traîtres et des vents forts
le voyage depuis la namibie est
facilitée par des bandes est favorable
[Musique]
nous avons suivi la côte namibienne
connu sous le nom de skeleton cos c'est
un cimetière de navires
[Musique]
les navires font naufrage les marins
sont jetés sur la cote
il ne reste que des squelettes
[Musique]
en débarquant le capitaine s'est cassé
deux côtes nous sont donc forcés de
rester en namibie une semaine entière
[Musique]
comment tu te sens pas terrible c'est
parti pour huit ou neuf jours avec un
peu de chance
une fois que les bleus auront disparu je
me sentirai mieux
pendant que le capitaine récupère nous
en profitons pour voyager un peu et
rencontrer la tribu himba
[Musique]
là
t'as fait quoi comme j'ai dit bonjour
[Musique]
m
les femmes ne se lasse jamais mais se
couvrent d'argile la nuit elle tombe et
le matin elle en remède pour en avoir
sur le corps tout au long de la journée
ça y est elle est partante
elle est à toi il dit que si tu dis
avoir une femme tout le village va rire
de toi
les pauvres ont deux ou trois femmes les
riches jusqu'à 8 les familles bas sont
réputés pour être très joli
un grand merci pour l'intérêt que vous
portez à notre expédition
le capitaine se sent mieux nous avons
reçu un accueil très chaleureux au yacht
club local
comme quoi les marins se comprennent
toujours nous avons été si bien traités
nous n'avons pas payé pour la bière ou
les chambres les invités de russie
[Musique]
ici dans ce coin éloigné ils ne savent
pas ce qu'est la russie
certains connaissent la russie les ours
gagarine c'est un nom célèbre ici nous
en avons appris au sujet de la namibie
peu de la russie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on compte traverser l'océan atlantique
de la namibie au brésil en un mois
[Musique]
il fait plus de 30 degrés est beaucoup
plus chaud en plein soleil
le pont est brûlant et on étouffe à
l'intérieur de la tente
[Musique]
migros
c'est
eh oui
ça
[Musique]
trop difficile
i think i
[Musique]
à lomé
qu'est ce que vous faites
le soleil vous a tapé sur la tête
[Musique]
si les yeux
moi
et mon baume qui est mon
la regarde 4 aileron côte à côte
regardez ce sont des squales eux les
féroces des requins des grands-fonds
connus pour leurs dents acérées et leur
comportement extrêmement agressif quand
la mer est calme il remonte et arrachent
des morceaux de chair à déballer 26
requins nous a pris pour une baleine et
s'en est pris à l'une des coques pour
éviter de couler nous avons dû colmater
les trous et pour cela nous avons
utilisé les cuillères on terminera les
réparations et faire ce qu'on a à faire
c'est faisable
seulement voilà on sera sur le qui vive
jusqu'aux tout derniers jours
qui sait combien de bestioles mordre ou
encore les coques est ce que ce sera une
par une ou tout à la fois
[Musique]
vous pensiez que ce serait une promenade
on va encore fortaleza au fortaleza
yacht club le club nautique de fortaleza
nous traversons l'océan atlantique
un accueil solennel nous attend au
brésil
[Musique]
il sent que les locaux étaient au
courant de ce périple
[Musique]
la prochaine étape de l'expédition sera
très difficile et elle prendra trois
mois nous naviguerons vers l'océan
pacifique via la mer des caraïbes
oleg line offre vient d'intégrer
l'équipage c'est un skipper expérimenté
[Musique]
nous passons devant les îles de trinité
et tobago sous une pluie incessante
arrivé dans la tempête c'est devenu la
norme
[Musique]
le prochain arrêt et saint domingue la
capitale de la république dominicaine
le paradis terrestres existent
pour l'équipage le principal intérêt est
la statue de christophe colomb dans le
parc columbus
je
c'est là qu'a été enterrés colons que je
grands explorateurs
[Musique]
on a reconnu christian nous sommes à la
dernière demeure du grand marin colons
si chez nous voir cet endroit est très
important pour notre expédition
c'était un grand homme qui a découvert
la moitié de la planète et est à
l'origine d'une nouvelle ère
[Musique]
nous reprenons notre voyage direction
cuba
nous arrivons au port santiago de cuba
nous demandons l'autorisation d'accord
bonjour monsieur
bienvenue à santiago des coups bas
la compagnie
en attendant les formalités nous faisons
le tour de santiago de cuba la deuxième
plus grande ville de l'île de la liberté
g
là
[Musique]
j
et enfin le mexique dernière escale
avant le grand océan pacifique
[Musique]
be blood
[Rires]
[Musique]
salut pour voyager à travers la
polynésie française nous prenons avec
nous au le gars qui sera notre
interprète
c'est mon premier voyage sur le séant
[Musique]
maintenant les seuls terrible mexicaine
nous avons quitté la côte mexicaine et
partons pour le pacifique
c'est la raison pour laquelle je me suis
joint à l'expédition
l'océan pacifique nous a accueillis
chaleureusement à la hauteur de son nom
inventé par magellan
carteron fantômas il nous a accueilli
tellement bas qu'ils pacifiquement
[Musique]
près du nicaragua il ya peut-être des
vents forts mais nous verrons bien le
contre-courant et pénible cher
magellan à naviguer dans le pacifique
pendant quelques mois et n'a jamais vu
une seule tempête assez venise mais on
sait bien que la plupart des typhons se
produisent dans le pacifique
et au bout d'une semaine le temps
changent
nous avons eu des vents forts des
tempêtes incessantes le vent a commencé
par abîmer le mât nous avons failli
chavirer
on était quatre à tirer la voile mais
sans succès
on a su le bc dieu merci et même sans
voile nous avons été entraînés dans des
directions inconnues s'accrocher au fond
avec nos ondes
c'est ok les gars on est sauf
aucune idée d'où on va mais en étant
vide et on flotte
à la guerre comme à la guerre le
déjeuner c'est sacré
nous approchons de puerto ayora la plus
grande ville des galapagos
[Musique]
nous devons reconstituer nos réserves de
nourriture et d'eau et bien sûr réparer
le catamaran endommagées par les
tempêtes les galapagos est un endroit
des plus intéressants j'ai vu des
animaux qu'il y avait dans mes manuels l
école et bien sûr les tortues elles
vivent si longtemps de nombreuses années
et contrairement à nous vous savez elle
ne fume pas et ne doivent pas
[Musique]
kenny
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
par là à gauche on tourne le cap nous
approchons des îles marquises
l'une des premières invitations et celle
de l'école sainte-anne à nous sommes
présentés par le maire de lille étienne
les étudiants locaux ne savent rien de
la russie et veulent en savoir plus
c'est un pays très au nord
nous n'avons pas d'océan chaud mais les
russes aiment voyager aussi les enfants
sont ravis ils sont fascinés par la
taille de la russie suit un échange de
chansons
[Musique]
génial nous quittons désormais les si
accueillante îles marquises pour les
îles cook
du calme du calme et kenny détends toi
je pense que c'est un signe d'unité avec
la nature si l'homme et la nature n'ont
pas peur l'un de l'autre ils sont unis
ils sont ensemble
[Applaudissements]
la regarde un requin-tigre regarde il
est parti à gauche
j'envoie un gris il n'est pas seul
ils touchent presque le bateau en voilà
en plus gros il y en a 2 les gars il
doit faire six ou sept mètres un truc
comme ça
il est juste en dessous géré par là vers
la ville rarotonga la plus grande des
îles cook
[Musique]
un homme s'est approché de nous je suis
chaman en chef et neveu de la reine la
reine vous invite side pour que vous
viviez longtemps merci d'une femme aux
cheveux gris elle à 93 ans elle a servi
du thé et nous a donné une pagaie
accepté cet ancien pas gai polynésienne
ainsi la chance sera toujours avec vous
et les bonbons vous accompagneront car
ce que vous faites fait revivre un art
maritime anciens courtois
t
si m
[Musique]
les mots
le voyage touche à sa fin lors de la
dernière étape de notre croisière autour
du monde
nous avons en quelque sorte compris en
quoi consiste le monde
ce que pourrait être le but de son
existence et du rôle que les humains il
jouerait à 1000
j'ai changé j'ai appris à me connaître
je sais que désormais toute ma vie et
partagés entre un avant et un après
quels secrets l'oci en matière révélé je
suis une particule de l'univers juste
une particule vivante celle m
et je me suis amélioré
[Musique]
l'océan est un être vivant gigantesque
il n'est pas comme les humains c'est un
autre type de vie mais il est vivant
[Musique]
on approche de phuket l'endroit où ce
voyage autour du monde à commencer enfin
à la maison
oui on rentre à la maison
[Musique]
[Rires]
vivre
nous y voilà j'aimerais vraiment voir
comme ça
[Musique]
[Rires]
j'ai mis les pieds sur ma terre natale
et je me suis dit je n'irai plus jamais
en mer avec ces gens j'en ai marre pour
toujours pour toujours ça a duré deux
ans
[Musique]
une fois rentré j'ai dit devant toutes
les caméras que je naviguerai plus
jamais sur l'océan
ça nous est étranger les gens sont nés
sur terre et doivent vivre sur terre
[Musique]
mais maintenant je rêve de nouveaux
voyages je conçois de nouveaux navires
et je pense que je ne m'arrêterai pas là
[Musique]
et nous voilà de nouveau en route pour
l'océan
[Musique]